[Music]
it's time
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and of
course things have been just
super exciting lately and things are
getting even more exciting as we have
some new
falcon and the winter soldier news and a
rumor for the release date for the
official trailer
for the falcon and the winter soldier
and this is coming along with the
rumored release date for the wanda
vision series as well since we don't
actually have an official release date
for that yet
but don't worry i'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win an iron spider funko pop
just subscribe comment below and like
this video so filming for the falcon and
the winter soldier in prague has just
wrapped up
this means that filming for the entire
series is most likely complete
at this point there are no other
shootings that are scheduled on
locations at this point in time however
they could do reshoots but they'll most
likely do those in the studio
now this is great news because of course
the completion of the filming means that
the completion of the editing process
could come pretty soon which means a
full official trailer is not that far
away
also side note shang chi and the legend
of the 10 rings has just finished
completion of filming as well
but since that's an actual movie and not
a disney plus show the odds of us
getting a first look or
trailer for that anytime soon is
probably not likely but since falcon and
the winter soldier is simply going to
disney plus
and filming is usually what caused the
delays in the phase 4
schedule especially for the disney plus
series this means that there most likely
won't be any more delays for the falcon
and the winter soldier and that we can
get the teaser trailer soon
and as i mentioned there is a rumored
teaser trailer release date and right
now that rumored date
is thanksgiving november 26th so
about a month away now i've been asked a
lot about this rumor and unfortunately i
can't confirm if this is a legitimate
release date or not
however i will say that there has been a
rumored release date for the one
division series and that
is thanksgiving november 26th as well
again
this is not confirmed however it would
make a ton of sense if they would attach
a falcon in the winter soldier trailer
special look something of that sort with
the release of one division they did
something similar to this with the
mandalorians premiere and the rise of
skywalker so disney has done this before
so it is entirely possible however the
release date for the one division series
is not yet confirmed
it could be on thanksgiving but we're
not sure but something that we are sure
about is that the trailer is right
around the corner now that filming is
complete nothing is really stopping
marvel studios from putting together
their official trailer and the only
thing that people are really worried
about at this point in time right now is
that the falcon and the winter soldier
is most likely coming out before we get
black widow
and black widow and falconer and the
winter soldier are supposed to connect
to each other
however based off of everything that
we've kind of heard so far the way that
they're going to connect is probably
going to be
the thunderbolt setup some type of
connection with thunderbolt ross the
super soldier serum and of course
him putting together his new team in
which case the order doesn't necessarily
matter if they're both setting up the
same thing it's not
that big of a spoiler because we'll
either find it out from black widow or
we'll find it out from the falcon in the
winter soldier either way we're
discovering the same thing
so the continuity of it all doesn't
really get that messed up plus we
don't really know when we're going to
get black widow at this point in time
they continue to push black widow's
theatrical release date back
and theaters aren't exactly doing really
well right now we've had one major
theater change shut down and another
says that they might declare bankruptcy
soon so unfortunately as of right now it
doesn't look like any theatrical release
dates are going to be coming anytime
soon it's more likely going to be a
shift to video on demand on disney plus
but regardless of that fact it does look
like the falcon in the winter soldier is
coming before black widow and will most
likely get that official trailer with
the one division series at some point in
time during its release
so right now that is rumored to be
thanksgiving although it's not confirmed
but the great news is we do know we are
getting one division in 2020 which means
we are getting the falcon in the winter
soldier trailer
in 2020. i'll be sure to do an update if
we find out anything more about the
trailer so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news
down in the comments below let me know
which marvel phase 4 project you were
looking forward to
the most personally right now i'm really
just excited for the wanna vision to
start things off and to see how crazy it
gets but let me know yours in the
comments
don't forget to like this video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof